une rencontre intimement liée à la
maladie d'alzheimer
nous sommes à l'association france
alzheimer martinique l'actualité pour
ces familles
ce sont ces quatre médicaments qui ne
seront plus remboursés à compter du 1er
août prochain des médicaments qui
traitent les symptômes de la maladie
je pense que même quand nous vous allez
du mal acquis la pluie un médicament
parle d'un peut-être quatre papas le
malade lui-même le parle
et puis du jour au lendemain le supprime
on lui dit que ça ne sert à rien mais
c'est plus que ça ne sert plus à rien et
ce n'est pas à bout c'est parce que ça
ne sert à rien on va se poser quand même
des questions
c'est ce que je me dis moi je me pose
des questions une décision annoncée par
madame la ministre de la santé lundi
dernier qui interpelle plus d'un
ces médicaments étaient censés améliorer
facultés cognitives et puis surtout
améliorer les comportements des mages ce
sont les médicaments qui coûte très cher
donc le risque que nous avons c'est que
maladie ne soit pas pu soigner parce que
le médecin
le médicament est allé en mousse et il
ne va certainement pas là presque rien
et même si le prescrit n'est pas sûr que
la famille va l'acheter c'est vrai que
la ministre a dit que les sommes
économisées vont être reportées sur des
appuis des thérapeutiques non
médicamenteuses
mais on est obligé d'attendre pour voir
si les professionnels sont un peu
dubitatif est en attente d'une réelle
d'un réel transfert de ces médicaments
les médicaments pour la maladie
d'alzheimer ont coûté 90 millions
d'euros à la sécurité sociale en 2015
probablement moins je pense dans les
années qui ont suivi parce que
leurs prescriptions a largement diminué
déjà je doute que 90 millions d'euros
affectés à la prise en charge humaine
parce que finalement les autres
alternatives sont aussi de mettre plus
de personnes à disposition des malades
puissent être visible on ne sait pas du
tout comment va se faire c'est ce
transfert de de financement aujourd'hui
la maladie d'alzheimer touche près de
9000 personnes en martinique plus de 900
milles en france